i
[Música]
ah
la edición 2020 del índice global de
impunidad del comité para la protección
de periodistas advierte que méxico es el
país más mortífero para periodistas de
todo el hemisferio occidental y empeoró
un lugar al ubicarse ahora en el sexto
sitio solo debajo de siria somalia irak
sudán del sur y afganistán en 2020 han
sido asesinados por lo menos cuatro
periodistas por su labor y la cifra de
homicidios no resueltos es de 26 para
esta década el reporte reconoce que la
justicia logró sentencias para algunos
autores materiales de los asesinatos de
miroslava breach y javier valdez dos de
los casos más emblemáticos sin embargo
los autores intelectuales siguen impunes
el gobierno de lópez obrador asegura el
reporte no está ayudando a resolver el
problema y la fiscalía especial para
delitos contra la libertad de expresión
ha evitado atraer los casos durante la
actual administración el reporte expresa
además preocupación por la reciente
extinción entre otros fideicomisos del
fondo para la protección de defensores
de derechos humanos y periódico
[Música]
con 15 asesinatos no resueltos en este
último decenio brasil entra en el octavo
lugar en la lista de países con mayor
impunidad ante estos crímenes según el
comité de protección de periodistas
basado en nueva york' aquí en brasil un
caso reciente muestra la dificultad de
ejercer la profesión de periodista en el
país este lunes fue secuestrado un
reportero de una red de televisión local
en el estado amazónico de roraima fue
encontrado al día siguiente con
fracturas en brazos y piernas el último
asesinato de un periodista en brasil fue
en mayo pasado cuando mataron a tiros a
leonardo vinieron que denunciaba casos
de corrupción en la revista digital de
su ciudad a la rúa más cerca del río de
janeiro en su última asamblea general la
sociedad interamericana de prensa
denunció la violencia física contra los
periodistas brasileños pero también los
ataques de las propias autoridades
contra los comunicadores
[Música]
según el informe en enero agosto 2020 de
la o en ese espacio público sobre la
situación general del derecho a la
libertad de expresión los periodistas en
venezuela han sido blancos de los
cuerpos de seguridad quienes limitan la
difusión de informaciones y opiniones
haciendo uso de los distintos mecanismos
de coacción en los ocho primeros meses
del año ocurrieron 59 detenciones la
mayoría contabilizadas en el mes de
marzo a propósito del estado de alarma y
el decreto de 40 en anunciada por el
collage maduro las coberturas vinculadas
a la pandemia oa la escasez de gasolina
que atraviesa venezuela han sido las
principales causas para arremeter contra
los trabajadores de la prensa asimismo
el informe de la ong señala que se
registraron tres muertes de periodistas
todas desarrolladas bajo extrañas
circunstancias y la policía aún está
investigando las el 43% de los
victimarios está integrado por los
distintos cuerpos de seguridad del
estado la guardia nacional bolivariana
el 6 ep 6 la dije sin acumula en la
mayor cantidad de ataques
[Música]